مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج هذه ابرز عناوين
اليوم
بعد توافق مع واشنطن على ارسال دبابات
ابرامز
همم كان في اربع مناطق رقميه جديده اعلن
عنها في المخطط امين منطقه الرياض يكشف عن
فرص استثماريه ضخمه للاعلانات واربع مناطق
رقميه
دراسه حديثه تكشف عن تعرض
80% من الموظفين في السعوديه لاعراض تتعلق
بالصحه النفسيه
ومن ملفاتنا متنوعه في الرابعه كذلك
بشراكه سعوديه ايطاليه التنفيذ يبدا في
مشروع سما للاخوت والسفن الفاخره
على مدى عامين الرابعه وثقوا قصه انقاذ
الطفل سلمان تجاوز ازمه قلبيه في اشهره
الاولى
حياكم الله بعد شد وجذب وافقت المانيا
اخيرا على ارسال الدبابات اليوباردي الى
اوكرانيا وقال المستشار الالماني
قرار تزويده اوكرانيا بدبابات اليوبارد 2
ثم بعد حوار مع الحلفاء اكيد المستشار
الالماني خلال كلمه له ان بلاده ستقدم
ستدببات ليوبارد اثنان لاوكرانيا وقالت
برلين ايضا انها ستوفر الصيانه والذخيره
لدبابات اليو بارد التي ستذهب لاوكرانيا
سبايدر مان
مع الولايات المتحده بتقديم مركبات برادلي
وستقدم المانيا وفرنسا المزيد من
المساعدات سنقدم 6 دبابات اليبر
المهندسين على صيانه الدبابات
رحبت رئاسه الاوكرانيه بموافقه برلين على
تسليمها دبابات اليوبارد مع ثبارته خطوه
اولى ودعت الدول الغربيه الى تزويدها
بمزيد من الاسلحه لسد الجيش الروسي وقال
رئيس الاداره الرئاسيه اندري يير ماك على
تيليجرام تم اتخاذه خطوه اولى مطالبا بان
يقوم تحالف دولي بتزويد في دبابات ثقيله
واضاف نحن بحاجه لعدد كبير من دبابات
ليوبارد
ونتابع هذه الاخبار العاجله ايضا اسفل
الشاشه
شغلتس يقول بان المانيا لن تقدم مقاتلات
الى اوكرانيا او نرسل جنود الان او حتى في
المستقبل اذا هذه الصور المباشره التي
نقولها لكم ايضا من كلمه المستشار
الالماني
لم يقدم مقاتلات الى اوكرانيا او نورسين
الجنودا في المستقبل يتحدث عن ارسال جنود
الى اوكرانيا كان قد اكد شولت بان
العلاقات الامريكيه الالمانيه في افضل
حالاتها
ووصف الرئيس الامريكي بانه شريف يكون همم
جيد
وكذلك قال همم بانهم اتخذوا قرار ارسال
دبابات
لم يكن قرارا فريدا همم ولو كان منفردا
الا كان طبعا عرض المانيا الى الخطر
عد الى هذه النشره في ذات الملف اا اكد
المتحدث باسم الكريملهند متر بيسكوب ان
الدبابات التي سيوفرها الغرب لاوكرانيا
ستحترق
صدرت مؤخر الكثير من البيانات الاعلاميه
والتسريبات وما الى ذلك من المانيا
والولايات المتحده من المفهوم انه لا تسير
الامور بثلاثه هناك في حلف الناتو بخصوص
توفر الدبابه هناك مبالغه في تقدير
الامكانات التي ستضيفها الدبابات للقوات
الاوكرانيه انه وهم اخر خطير للغايه هذه
الدبابات تحترق مثل كل الدبابات الاخرى
الفرق هي انها تكلف الكثير وكل هذا سيقع
على عاتق دافع الضرائب الاوروبيين في
المقام الاول
من برلين تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض اذن بعد الشده والجذب وافقت
المانيا وفققه الحكومه وعلى لسان اولوف
شولت ايضا الذي اكد ارسال المقاتل ارسال
عفوا ارسال طبعا الدبابات ليوبارد اثنين
الى اوكرانيا لكنه في ذات الوقت نفى ارسال
اي مقاتلات او اي جنود الى اوكرانيا في
المستقبل ما الذي تضمنه هذا الخطاب حتى
الان
اهلا بك يعني هو ما زال يتحدث هي جلسه
استجواب في الواقع من قبل النواب لي رئيس
او للمستشار الالماني الذي هو رئيس
الحكومه ايضا بطبيعه الحال هو حديث عن
الطائره كان ردا على جواب كنا ردا على
سؤال من احد النواب الحزب البديل لالمانيا
هذا الحزب اليمين المتطرف هو حزب دليل كان
يسار للمطرب فقط يعرضون ارسال هذه
الدبابات هذا النائب كان يساله متى نتوقف
عن هذا الدعم انت تقول يعني هو يقول لش
انت تقول الان بانه علينا ان نرسل هذه
الدبابات
لمساعده اوكرانيا ولكن متى نتوقف هل نتوقف
يعني بعد ان يرسل الجنود بعد ان يرسل
طائرات اين هي نقطه التوقف فكان رد تشارلز
بانه نحن لن نصل الى هذه النقطه لن نصل
الى ارسال طائرات لانه يعني بانه المانيا
باكملها ستورت في الحرب وعاده وكرر بانه
هناك حرس رغم هذا القرار الان بارسال هذه
فبعد على ان لا يكون هناك تعريض لامن
المانيا للخطر على ان لا يكون هناك تورط
مباشر للنيتو في هذه الحرب وهو في الواقع
يعني في كل يعني هذا التبرير الذي يعطيك
لقراره في الموافقه على ارسال هذه
الدبابات الالمانيه كان يشدد دائما وفي
يعني كل نقطه تقليديه تقريبا على انه هذا
القرار لم ياتي منفردا من المانيا بل جاء
يعني بالتناسق وبالتنسيق وبعد مشاورات
مطوله مع الحلفاء عدد بريطانيا وفرنسا
التي قررته ايضا ارسال دباباتهم دباباتهم
الخاصه يعني المحليه الصنع وقلب انه هناك
تحالف من الدول ايضا الاوروبيه والتي قررت
هذه الدبابات الالمانيه لذلك كان هناك حرص
على التشديد بانه القرار ليس قرار الماني
منفرد يعني من متابعتك خلال الايام
الماضيه في ما يخص المانيا تحديدا وارسال
دبابات لي اثنين ما الذي كان يخشاه شولتس
من ابداء الموافقه همم يعني بعد ان تقدمت
اوكرانيا بهذا الطلب بعد ان طلبت حتى
الولايات المتحده من المانيا ان تزود
اوكرانيا بهذا النوع من الدبابات لماذا
كان متردد باعطاء الموافقه في هذه الخطوه
جيدا لانه ينتمي للحزبه الاشتراكي والحزب
الاشتراكي همم الديمقراطي الالماني بشكل
عام هو كان حزب يعتبر مقرب من روسيا هو
يعني هو من اسس لسياسه تعرف لسياسه
الاطفال التي التقرب من الشرق في ظل الحرب
البارده وهذه يعني كان صعب جدا بالنسبه
لهذا الحزب ان يتخذ خطوات كالخطوات التي
اتخذها في الاشهر القليله الماضيه وكان
هناك خشيه من انه هكذا قرار سيؤدي الى
زياده الشرخ وربما يعيد ترسيخ ما كان ايام
الحرب البارده من هذا الانقسام الكبير بين
روسيا وبين الدول الغربيه لذلك كان هذا
التردد هو لا يصفه تردد هو يقول بانه حرص
على الاقل يعني على دراسه نتائج هذه
الخطوه وحارس قال لا نعود يعني لفتره
سابقه وعلى ان يكون هناك تنسيق
انسام همم الشركاء الغربيين همم الاخرين
لانه يعني الحزب الاشتراكي هو الوحيد في
يعني الوحيد بدنا نحسب الكبيره التي الذي
كان يتمهل لتمارضنا القول يعني كي لا نقول
يعارض اتخاذ قرار في ارسال هذه الدبابات
الحزبين الصغيرين كما ذكرت وما حزبين يعني
متطرفان ليس لهما عدد كبير من المقاعد ولا
يمثلان عدد كبير من همم الشعب الالماني
ايضا السؤال كذلك عن همم يعني همم ما قاله
عن الولايات المتحده وكان الحديث ربما عن
ان ارسال هذه الدبابات مشروط يعني تعهد
الولايات المتحده بارسال ايضا دباباتها
ابرامز الى همم اوكرانيا ما الذي ذكره شغل
عن العلاقه الالمانيه الامريكيه وعن
التنسيق في ارسال هذه الدبابات في كلمته
التي لا زالت جاريه حتى اللحظه
بالفعل كان ملفت يعني لغايه ما بدات هذه
المقابله معكم بانه لم يتحدث تحديدا وبشكل
مفصل عن هذا الاتفاق الذي يتم التداول به
لم يقل بانه واشنطن وافقت على ارسال
دبابات عبرنس هو قال فقط يعني اكتفى
بالحديث عن المشاورات وتنسيق بين الحلفاء
وقال ايضا بانه يعني عندما سئل سؤال عام
عن علاقته بالولايات المتحده لان هناك
الان من ينتقد بان كل هذا التردد من طرف
المستشعر الالماني همم قد يؤدي الى تدهور
العلاقات او يعني اساء لسمعه المانيا لدى
الولايات المتحده تحديدا لذلك السؤال كان
عام فجاء رد تشارلز ايضا ردا عاما هو قال
بانه همم جو بايدر الرئيس الامريكي هو
حليف قوي همم المانيا و بانه العلاقه
بينهما ممتازه لذلك لم يكن هناك حديثا على
ما وافقت الولايات المتحده على ان ترسله
ومتى لم يتحدث بهذا يعني بهذا الاتفاق
وكانت قبل قليل دير شبيك الصحيفه
الالمانيه قد تحدثت بين الدول الاوروبيه
تسعى لارسال 80 دبابات اليوبارد الى
اوكرانيا على كل حال شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه المعلومات التفاصيل من برلين مراسله
العربيه راغبه
اذا هو في اول تصريح بعد اعلان ارسال
دبابات اليوبارد الى اوكرانيا اكد الرئيس
الروسي بلادي ميرفت ان على بلاده مسؤوليه
حمايه اراضيها التاريخيه وقال بوتين ان
روسيا ولدت كدوله واحده متعدده الجنسيه
وعليها ان تحافظ على ذلك مشيرا الى ان هدف
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا هو حمايه
روسيا والروس
وفي اول رد فعل غربي
بريطانيا ان المانيا اتخذت قرار الصحيح
واتباعا بدات الدول الغربيه باعلان
استعدادها رساله دبابات الى اوكرانيا
عن الحكومه السويديه قولها انها لا تستعد
وتزويد اوكرانيا
122 همم 122 وهي النسخه السويديه من
دبابات اليوم الالمانيه بما صرح وزير
الدفاع السويدي
اوكرانيا بالدبابات لكنه سار الى امكانيه
حدوث ذلك في مرحله لاحقه هذا ويمتلك الجيش
السويدي نحو 120 دبابه من طراز ستريتس فان
اما في امريكا فابادت مصادر رسميه امريكيه
لشبكه سي ان بان واشنطن تتجاهل الاعلان عن
ارسال 30 دبابه من طراز ابرامز لاوكرانيا
خلال الاسبوع الجاري المصادر اشارت الى ان
الاداره الامريكيه تضع المساءات الاخيره
على خطوط الارسال كما اباحت المصادر
المسؤوله لشبكه الامريكيه ان قرار التسليم
اكيد لكن عمليه الارسال قد تستغرق وقتن
الرابعه مستمره وفي بعد قليل ايضا
دراسه حديثه تكشف عن تعرض 80% من الموظفين
في السعوديه لاعراض تتعلق بالصحه النفسيه
حياكم الله من جديد الرياض تطلق الفرصه
الاضخم للاعلانات الخارجيه هذا ما اعلنه
امين المنطقه الامير فيصل بن عياف خلال
ملتقى الاستثمار البلدي فرص 2023 تستهدف
الفرصه تشغيله وصيانه لوحات الاعلانات
الخارجيه امين الرياضه كذا ان العاصمه
تنافس دول العالم على الاستثمار وراس
المال والمواهب
المجال الاعلانات بشكل عام من المجالات
الواعده والسوق الحمد لله فيه كبير جدا في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه عامه وفي الرياض
خاصه قبل يمكن عده اشهر اطلقنا المخطط
الاعلاني والمخطط الحمد لله نظم عمليه
الاعلانات داخل المدينه بشكل كبير كان فيه
اربع مناطق رقميه جديده اعلن عنها في
المخطط كان في اكثر من 1400 موقع اعلاني
جديد كتم تنظيم عن طريق المخطط اليوم كنت
سعيد جدا باطلاق فرصه قد تعدل اكبر في
مجال الاعلانات ليس فقط في همم في مستوى
السعوديه وليس فقط على الشرق الاوسط على
مستوى العالم باذن الله في يومه الاول
والثاني شهيده ملتقى للاستثمار البلدي
توقيعه عدد من الاتفاقيات المحليه
والدوليه وطرح اكثر من خمسه الاف فرصه
استثماريه من جهه بلديه وحكوميه في قطاعات
متعدده وسط دعوات للمستثمرين لاستغلال
الفرصه التفاصيل مع زينب عبد المحسن
الحالي
اكثر من 5000 فرصه استثماريه مطروحه امام
الالاف من المستثمرين الصغار منهم والكبار
في ملتقى فرص للاستثمار البلدي
بمشاركه واسعه محليه ودوليه
ندعو جميع المهتمين للقدوم للمعرض
للنظر في هذه العدد الهائل من الفرصه
الاستثماريه الفرصه استثماريه ليست حصرا
همم على فئه معينه من المستثمرين وانما
تستهدف جميع شرائح المستثمرين من صغار
المستثمرين تبدا من الانشطه الصغيره جدا
وصولا الى كبار المستثمرين همم في انشطه
وقطاعات مختلفه جدا الملتقى يضموا جلسات
وورش عمل تتمحور ووضيعها حول اداره المدن
واستقلالها اقتصاديا واستعراض نماذج لمدن
عالميه
ومناقشته اعمال منصه فراس التي استطاعت
خلال فتره قصيره طرح سبعه 37,000 فرصه بقي
بسبعه مليارات ريال احنا نتنوع في الفرصه
الثماريه لليوم موجوده من انشطه صناعيه
لدينا كذلك انشطه تجاريه سواء كانت
ترفيهيه تعليميه
فحاولنا انه همم يعني نغطي جميع النشاطات
اللي موجوده
ونستعرضها اليوم مع الزوار والمستثمرين في
الجناح فرصنا طبعا متعدده في مناطق
المملكه جميعها تجاريه ومحطات وقود
واستثماريه بشكل عام لمده تصل الى 50 سنه
من عشر سنوات الى 50 سنه الفرس فالحمد لله
في اقبال كبير على الفرص ان شاء الله رايح
ينتهي همم استقبال العروض في 31 جانوري
وان شاء الله القادم بيكون افضل باذن الله
ان شاء الله نطرح فرص القادمه باذن الله
تجربه كاس العالم في قطر تتناولها الدوحه
مدينه الضيف للمتعه فيما عقدت اتفاقيات
ومذكرات تفاهم من دوليه ومحليه
لتعزيز الاستثمار بالقطاع البلدي وسط حض
كبير من رواد الاعمال والمستثمرين
عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض
نشره المركز السعودي لتعزيز صحه نفسيه
دراسه تعنى بالصحه النفسيه في مكان العمل
الدراسه اجريت على عينه من الموظفين
والموظفات السعوديين خلال العام 2022
متابعوا تفاصيلها مع زميل العنود العبدلي
في مكان العمل جمله يعملوا الكثيره من
التساؤلات عن صحتنا النفسيه اثناء اداء
اعمالنا وتاثير بيئات العمل على الموظفين
سلبا وايجابا الامر الذي دعى مؤسسه تهون
والمركز السعودي لتعزيز الصحه النفسيه الى
اجراء دراسه بهذا الخصوص داخل السعوديه
الدراسه شملت اربعه الاف موظف وموظفه في
القطاعين العام والخاص في السعوديه وتوصلت
الى عده نتائج من ابرزها ان اربعه من كل
خمسه موظفين واجهوا عارضا واحدا على الاقل
مرتبطا بالصحه النفسيه خلال العام الماضي
20 22
34% من الموظفون يشعرون انهم لا يحصلون
على التقدير الكافي فيما يعتقد سبعه
وخمسون في المئه من الموظفين انهم يتعرضون
للضغط العصبي في مكان العمل وسته 36% من
الموظفين اكدوا انهم يتعرضون للحد الادنى
من التنمر ومن النتائج كتاب مشاهدينا ان
82% من المؤسسات لا تخصص اي ميزانيه
لمعالجه مسائل مرتبطه بالصحه النفسيه
لموظفيها ما هي الاعراض النفسيه الاكثر
شيوعا لدى الموظفين في المؤسسات السعوديه
52% من الموظفين وجهوا الاحتراق الوظيفي
لما يتعرضوا 46% منهم لقلق بشكل متكرر
واخيرا الضغط العصبي فيتعرض له ثمانيه
وثلاثون في المئه من الموظفين اثناء
ممارسه الاعمال اليوم
هل انت منفتح على الحديث عن صحتك النفسيه
في مكان عملك مع زملائك او المديرين سؤال
تم طرحه في هذه الدراسه
37% من الذين شاركوا في الدراسه مستعدون
للحديث عن صحتهم النفسيه بالرغم من تحفظ
الاناث خصوصا على هذه الخطوه
العلاج النفسي ادخال حياك
خليني اسالك لماذا هذه الدراسه فعليه ان
هي تشخص واقع الصحه النفسيه في يعني بين
الموظفين والموظفات في السعوديه
يعني اخذنا بالاعتبار انه العينه شمله
اربعه الاف موظفه طبعا مثل الدراسه هذه
مثل الدراسه هذه تعتبر من الدراسات
القليله سواء على المستوى
العربي او المستوى المحلي همم
انا ترى كنت اشر على على السماعه بس انا
كنت احكي على انه هذه الدراسه لاي مدى هي
فعليا تشخص واقع الصحه النفسيه عندنا
بمعنى انه هذه 4000 عينه هي اللي شملتها
هذه الدراسه فهل ممكن ناخذ هذه الارقام
وهذه الدراسه بانها واقعيه فعلا للي
قاعدين نعيش اليوم
دائما الدراسات بتعطينا عينه تعطينا
مؤشرات على ما يحدث داخل المجتمع الدراسه
الاكبر
فمثل هذه الدراسه نستطيع ان ناخذ نستطيع
ان نقول انها تعطينا همم رؤيه تعطينا همم
اساس للانطلاق من خلال النظر الى مستويات
الصحه النفسيه في بيئات العمل المختلفه
سواء على المستوى القطاع الخاص او القطاع
من المسؤول عن الصحه النفسيه للموظفين في
المؤسسات بطبيعه الحل المؤسسات في حداد
تاهيل مسؤوله لانها لابد ال- ال- لتوفير
المساله الصحه النفسيه او موضوع عن الصحه
النفسيه للعاملين فيها همم تحتاج الى
قرارات من اصحاب العمل الحداتهم يعني
المسؤولين في هذه الجهات المختلفه لانها
لن تكون همم مجانيه لابد ان تكون همم
تكون بشراهه مع جهات متخصصه في المجال ال-
ال- النفسي سواء كانت هذه المراكز حكوميه
مراكز خاصه تقدم مثل هذه الخدمات الخدمات
هذه ربما تكون خدمات وقائيه همم خدمات همم
تثقيفيه بالاضافه الى الخدمات العلاجيه
عندما يصاب افراد هذه الجهات ببعض المشاكل
الممتازه من النتائج الملفته انه 82% من
المؤسسات اصلا مش مخصص اي ميزانيه لمعالجه
هذه المسائل المسائل همم الصحه النفسيه
وغيرها تشوف انه طبيعي
قصور قصور في الجهات نفسها في معرفه مدى
اهميه اصلا همم الصحه النفسيه للموظف او
للعامل في الجهه ومدى واثر هذه الصحنه
النفسيه على انتاجيه الموظف في حذات لانه
همم اعتقد انه كثير من ال- ال- ال- الجهات
سواء كانت المؤسسات الحكوميه او العامه
خاصه تتاثر في مستوى صحه افرادها كل ما
كانت الافراد الاول العاملين في هذه
الجهات يتمتعون في صحه نفسيه عاليه
بالاضافه الى خلوهم من المشكله همم
النفسيه بالاضافه الى الضغوط همم المختلفه
كل ما كان اثر على الانتاجيه واثر على
العمل بشكل عام وعلى النتائج التي يستطيع
انه ال ال المسؤولين انهم يلمسونها خلال
فتره او خلال العمل في هذه القطاعات
المختلفه احنا عندنا مشكله في موضوع
الحديث عن الصحه النفسيه بمعنى انه همم هل
في انفتاح على الحديث في هذا الموضوع من
الجنسين انا اتحدث عن الذكر وعن همم
الانثى ويمكن اساسا اللي كان موجود في هذه
الدراسه همم انه بالرغم من تحفظ الاناء
طبعا خصوصا على هذه الخطوه فاحنا لدينا
37% ممن شارك في هذه الدراسه مستعد دول
الحديث عن صحه النفسيه فقط سبعه
او همم 37
63% همم لا يرغون وهذه نسبه كبيره همم انا
اعتقد هي ثقافه اا عامه وليست ثقافه خاصه
في العاملين فقط
وبالاضافه الى مساله الوصمه همم
الاجتماعيه في مساله
انك تتكلم مثلا عن انك تصاب بمشكلات نفسيه
او اضطرابات نفسيه بالاضافه الى مفهوم
الاضطراب النفسيه عندنا اللي هو المشكله
اللي يعتقد دائما الشخص المصاب في المرض
النفسي دائما
اجتماعيه قد تؤدي فيه الى انه يبتعد عن
الاخرين همم يشعر بالتقدير اقل الاخرين
الان لو قلنا انه 80% مثلا من ال همم من
الموظفين الموظفات في السعوديه حسب مثلا
هذه الدراسه يعانون على الاقل من من
اضطراب مثلا نفسي او من مشكله وجهه او من
غيره في التالي لاي ماده احنا ممكن نواجه
مشكله الاحتراق الوظيفه وتصبح فعليا تحتاج
لعلاج
صحيح
الاغلب ال ال العاملين سواء في القطاع
العام او القطاع الخاص هم يتعرضون
للاحتراق الوظيفي اذا لم تكن هذه الجهات
التي يعملون فيها تهتم في الجانب النفسي
فلا بد في ال ال ال المحصله ان يحصل
احتراق وظيفه لاداء العاملين فيها لماذا
لانه الجانب الوقائي الان متى تكون صحيح
نفسيا عندما تكون لديك المهارات ولديك
الامكانيات في التعامل مع الضغوطات التي
تواجهه وهذه لابد ان تتعرض لها سواء على
مستوى الشخصي او على المستوى العملي
وبالتالي اذا الجهات التي انا اعمل فيها
بالاضافه الى همم الشخص نفسه لا يستطيع ان
يتعامل مع مثل هذه الضغوط فلا بد ان يتعرض
الى مشكلات ربما تكون على علاقه في الاسره
كذلك وبالتالي ستعود على ايضا همم ايضا
سوف تؤثر على
العمل شكرا
رابع مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد قليل
فلم الخلاط بلس يتربى على قائمته افضل 10
افلام على نتفليكس مليون ونصف المليون
ساعه مشاهده
اوكرانيا بعد توافق مع واشنطن على ارسال
دبابات ابرامز
امين منطقه الرياض يكشف عن فرص استثماريه
ضخمه للاعلانات واربع مناطق رقميه
دراسه حديثه تكشف عن تعرض 80% من الموظفين
في السعوديه لاعراض تتعلق بالصحه النفسيه
وبشراكه سعوديه ايطاليه تنفيذ يبدا في
مشروع السما للوقود والسفن الفاخره
انقاذ الطفل سلمان تجاوز ازمه قلبيه في
الشهور الاولى
حياكم الله من جديد مئه وثلاثون خدمه
تقدمها منصه قوه التابعه لوزاره الموارد
البشريه في السعوديه هذه الخدمات تهدفه
لحفظ اطراف العلاقه التعقديه تمهيدا لسوق
اكثر جاذبيه واستقطابا للاستثمارات
القوه الرقميه التابعه لوزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه اكثر من 130
خدمه يستفيد منها كافه اطراف سوق العمل
حيث تهدف الى اتمته سوق العمل السعودي
وزياده الشفافيه والوضوح وحفظ حقوق اطراف
العلاقه ليصبح اكثر جاذبيه للاعمال
واستقطاب الاستثمارات
وتعمل قوى على اعاده هندسه اجراءات
الخدمات المقدمه في سوق العمل وتطويرها
منذ لحظه تاسيس الاعمال تقوم منصه قوى
بدعم المنشاه حتى مرحله التوسع عبر تقديم
لعدد الذي تحتاجه من التاشيرات ورصيد
النقل من فتره سماح لمده عام كامل من
برنامج التوطين نطاقات
وتنقسم الخدمات المقدمه الى المنشات الى
خدمات تتم بشكل فوري مثل خدمات التاشيرات
المهنيه واصدار وتجديد رخص العمل ولوائح
تنظيميه وكذلك اصدار شهاده السعوده كما
تتضمن خدمات المؤسسات عبر منصه قوى خدمه
المستشار الالكترونيه لاصحاب الاعمال
والتي من خلالها يتم عرض عدد من المؤشرات
الحيويه التي تهمه صاحب المنشاه
وخدمه التقارير الشهريه مع الرؤساء
التنفيذيين واعضاء مجلس اداره الشركات كما
تتضمنوا خدمه التنبيهات الاستفاقيه
المساعده في التخطيط وازاله اي عقبات تحول
دون نجاح الاعمال
ومن اهم مزايا من الصديق وايضا اشراق
الموظف في كل التعاملات التي تتعلق بحياته
المهنيه وامكانيه الاطلاع على السجل
والمؤهلات الوظيفيه ويمكن للموظف اضافه
الدورات التدريبيه ومشاركه الملف الوظيفي
عبر رابط خاص ومعرفه حقوقه الماليه
المستحقه واحتساب مكافاه نهايه الخدمه عبر
ادوات وحاسبه رقميه الجدير بالذكر ان منصه
قوى هي المنصه المعتمده لتوثيق العقود
الوظيفيه للموظفين السعوديين والمقيمين
حيث تم نقل الخدمه اليها من المؤسسه
العامه للتامينه الاجتماعيه خلال العام
الماضي 20 اثنين وعشرين
السعوديه كشفات تجمع الشرقيه صحيه عن
تفعيل شبكه الاتصال اللاسلكيه الالكترونيه
وفرق الاستجابه والتدخل السريع واوضح تجمع
الشرقيه الصحي ان النظام يعد الاول من
نوعه بالسعوديه حيث يمكن من اداره
الاستجابه للنقل في ارجاء المنطقه بدقه
وبنظام تتبع الكتروني بالاضافه لتمكين
التواصل الافتراضي بين المراكز والمسعفين
في الميدان والاداره الذكيه للدعم
اللوجستيه
من الدمام
مراسل العربيه زميل عبد الرحمن العصيمي
عبد الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض ما الذي يمكن ان
نعرفه عن هذا النظام الجديد يا عبد الرحمن
واللي نحنا هنشوفها معك الان خلال هذه
الجوله
صحيح نايف يعني جهود كبيره تبذلها وزاره
الصحه وتحديده التجمع شرقيه الصحي لمحاوله
سرعه الاستجابه للحالات وايضا البلاغات
اولا باول وياتي هذا النظام في اطار هذا
في هذه الجهود لمحاوله تسريع عمليه
الاستجابه اكثر فاكثر الحديث اكثر نايف
ينضم الي المهند ايضا المدير التنفيذي
لمركز التحكم بالموارد في تجمع الشرقيه
الدكتور مهند اولا نتكلم عن هذا همم
النظام كيف يعمل وما هي ابرز ملامح هذا
نظام الجديد حياك الله يا استاذ عبد
الرحمن ومرحله بقناه العربيه في تجمع
شرقيه الصحي طبعا قبل ما اشرح النظام انا
ودي اعطي نبذه بسيطه عن مركز التحكم
بالموارد حتى يفهمها المشاهد ليش فصلنا
لهذا النظام مركز التحكم من موارد هو مركز
مهمه الاساسي الرئيسيه وهي تقديم الخدمات
الطبيه العاجله المشتركه بين المستشفيات
يعني وركز على كلمه مشتركه لانه في خدمات
يجب المستشفى او مستشفى اخر حتى يتم
توفيرها واحنا اخذنا على اعتقنا ان نوفل
هذه الخدمات من ناحيه تقديمها بشكل يعني
سريع
هذا النظام دكتور مهند هذا العام خريطه
للمنطقه الشرقيه صحيح هذا الخريطه للمنطقه
الشرقيه وفيها تلاحظ انه فيها علامات هي
تدل على اماكن تمركز المسافرين همم طبعا
احنا في مركز التحكم الموارد عندنا ثلاث
خدمات رئيسيه اللي هي النقل الطبي
الاسعافى وكذلك همم برنامج الحالات او نقل
يعني المرضى بين المستشفيات السلام عليكم
كانت الحياه او عاجله او غير عاجله وكذلك
اداره الازمات الوكاله في تجمع شرقيه
صحيحه
انه همم هذا البرنامج تم ابتكاره وتطويره
هنا في تجمع شرقيه الصحيحه صحيح طبعا احنا
بدانا في برنامج همم في مشروعيه اللي هو
مركز الطبي وحده من التحديات اللي واجهتنا
انه لا بد ان يكون لدينا النظام همم يكون
فيه شباب بلاغ كمان هذا مثال همم احنا
الان يعني همم
من جزء من اللي نعمله نحاول ان نعرف مواقع
المسرفين او المراكز اللي همم الوحدات
الاسعافيه للمتنقله ولذلك تم انشاء هذا
البرنامج اللي هو يعتمد على الخرائط
المباشره من خلال نستطيع التواصل معهم
بشكل مباشر عن طريق الفيديو وكذلك عن طريق
اللاسلكي ومعرفه موقعهم همم بالتفصيل
وبالضبط في اي نقطه هم متواجدين الان هذا
يطيح من المجال نستعين باقرب همم فرقه
اساسيه لتوفير الخدمه بشكل عاجل طيب
الدكتور مهند اولا هذا البرنامج يعني انتم
بتحرصون من خلال تطويره وابتكاره الى سرعه
الاستجابه بالنسبه للبلغات المناقدات اخرى
ايضا هذا الهدف الرئيسي من هذا البرنامج
زي ما احنا نسميها 26 يعني همم معرفه
المجال اللحظي همم
بهذه الطريقه نعرف باي طريقه نوجهها
للمستشفى الطالب
طبعا هذا البرنامج يعني تم انشاءه
بالتعاون مع اللي يعني اداره التقنيه
والشباب في في اداره المعلومات اللي
اعطيهم العافيه بمجهودات فرديه وما بداوا
ببرنامج صغير سووا عليه تجارب همم احنا
علمناهم اننا نحتاج نضاف عليها خرائط
نحتاج في تخزين البيانات وفي النهايه
وصلنا لهذا البرنامج يعني الاكثر من رائع
شكرا جزيلا دكتور مهند نايف يعني كما
شاهدنا جهود كبيره تبذلها وزاره الصحه
لتحسين همم جوده الخدمات الصحيه المقدمه
للمواطنين والمقيمين ومن ضمنها ايضا تلقي
البلاغات عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا لك همم
على هذه الجوله والتجربه على الهواء من
الدماء مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
شكرا يا عبد الرحمن
بشراكه سعوديه ايطاليه بدات شركه كروز
السعوديه المملوكه بالكامل لصندوق
الاستثمارات العامه لتنفيذ مشروع سما حيث
تابع لها بمواصفات مميزه الذي من المقرر
ان يعكس التصميم الداخليه
على ان يتم الانتهاء من بنائه وتجهيزه
ليدخل المرحله التشغيليه خلال عام 2026
اخبار الرياضه مع زياد عبيدات
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا نايف واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
تبدا غدا منافسات بطولات كاس السوبر
السعودي لكره القدم عندما يلتقي الهلال مع
الفيحاء على ستاد الامير فيصل بن فهد في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض ويحتل الهلال
المركز الثاني في مسابقه الدوري فيما ياتي
الفيحاء في المركز الثالث عشر وتوجد فيحاء
بلقب مسابقه كاس الملك على حساب الهلال في
شهر مايو الماضي
وفي الدور نصف النهائي الثاني من هذه
المسابقه يلتقي النصر مع ضيفه الاتحاد على
استاد الملك فهد الدولي والتقى الفريقان
هذا الموسم في الدوري المحلي وانتهت
المباراه بالتعادل من دونيه اهداف ويتصدر
النصر الدوري وياتي الاتحاد ثالث ثانوي
ولم يخسر كلاهما سوى مره واحده هذا الموسم
اسفلت قرعه الدوري نصف النهائي لمسابقه
الدوري الامم الاوروبيه لكره القدم عن
مواجهه كرواتيا الفائزه بالميداليه
البرونزيه في بطوله كاس العالم الاخيره
امامه هولندا البلد المضيف فيما يلتقي
منتخب ايطاليا مع اسبانيا في المباراه
الثانيه للدوري النصف النهائي
وحسمت المنتخبات والاربعاء صدارها مجموعها
في المستوى الاول من البطوله العام الماضي
وستشارك في بطوله المنتخب في شهر يونيو
المقبل لتحديد الفائز بلقب بموسم 2022
2000-23
تعادل بايرن ميونخ مع ضيفه كونان بهدف لكل
منهما ضمن الجوله السابعه عشر من الدوري
الالماني لكره القدم تقدم كلنا عند
الدقيقه الرابعه عن طريق اللاعب التونسيه
لياسس خيري وفي الدقيقه 90 نجح اللاعب
جوشوا كيميتش بادراك التعادل البايرن من
تسديده بعيده المدى التعادل هو الثاني
للفريق البربري على التوالي ورغم التعادل
حفظه بايرن ميونخ على صدرته للدوري بس 36
نقطه بينما صعد كلنا الى المركز العاشر
باحدى و20 نقطه
ومن جانبه تقدم لا يبزق الى المركز الثاني
في ترتيب الدوري الالماني لكره القدم بعد
انتصاره الكبير على مضيفه شالكه وبسته
اهداف مقابل هدف واحد
سيطره الفريق الزائر مبكرا على المباراه
عندما تقدم في الدقيقه السابعه عن طريق
اللاعب اندريس سيلفا
واضاف من جميل الهدف الثاني لفريقه لافزيق
في الدقيقه الرابعه عشر من زمن هذه
المباراه
وعد اندرياس
لفريقه في الدقيقه الرابعه هو والاربعين
وقبل نهايه الشوط الاول نجح فيرنار باحراز
الهدف الرابع لفريقه في هذا اللقاء وبعد
الاستراحه سجل عن طريق كوزوكي لكن
الى خمسه اهداف قبل ان يختم يوسف بولسان
النتيجه بالهدف السادس
وليسعد لا يرزق الى المركز الثاني بثنتين
32 نقطه متاخرا باربع نقاط عن بايرن ميونخ
المتصدر بينما هي شالكه في المركز الثامن
عشر والاخير برصيد 9 نقاط للدوري الالماني
لكره القدم
عهد المدرب اركتنهاج بعمل كل شيء من اجل
لاعادته من اجل عوده نادي مانشستر يونايتد
الى منصات تتويج هذا الموسم وجاء تصريحات
المدرب الهولندي بينما يستعد اليونايتد
لاستقبال فريق نوتنجهام فورست في الدوري
نصف النهائي لمسابقه كاس رابطه الانديه
الانجليزيه
وكان اخر لقب لليونايتد هو الفوز بلقب
بمسابقه الدوري الاوروبي موسم 2017
وتحت قياده المدرب البرتغالي جوزيه
مورينيو ويقف في يونايتد على بعد
مباراهتين فقط من محاوله الفوز بلا قرن قد
يرفع معنويات الفريق وجماهيره ويعلن عن
بدايه مرحله جديده للنادي الانجليزيه
يلتقي الليل برشلونه مع ريال سوسيداد ضمن
الدور ربع النهائي لمسابقه كاس ملك
اسبانيا لكره القدم
ويمر برشلونه بفتره جيده هذه الايام حيث
نجح بتحقيق اول لقب له تحت قياده تشادي
عندما فاز بكاس السوبر الاسباني الاسبوع
الماضي قبل ان يعود ويهزم خيتافي في
الدوري المحلي من جانبه يمر الريال
سوسيداد بسلسله من الانتصارات ويسع
الانحفاظ عليها في اختبار صعب امام متصدر
الدوري الاسباني
انضمها المحامي الذي شارك في الدفاع عن
اللاعب الارجنتيني ميسي الى فريق المحامين
الذي يدافع عن اللاعب البرازيلي داني
الفيش والذي يواجه تهمه الاعتداء الجنسي
وسوف يحاول المحامي المعروف كريستوبال
مارتل مساعدتها دفاع قضيته وقد افاد
تقارير اعلاميه اسبانيه ان افراد اسرته
طلبوا اجراء التغييرات في هيئه الدفاع عنه
بعد سجنه من دونك كفاله وكان مارتن ضمن
فريق الدفاع الذي عندنا ميسي بتهمه التهرب
من الضرائب في اسبانيا وتم الحكم عليه
بالسجل 21 شهرا رغم انه لم يقضي يوما
واحدا في الحبس بعد وقفه تنفيذ هذه
العقوبه
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك نايف
[موسيقى]
شكرا زياد
ولد بثقب في قلبه كبره واصبح يلعب مع
اخوته لا يعلم تفاصيل ما حدث معه الكاميرا
العربيه وثقت حالته منذ ان كان عمره ثلاثه
اشهر حتى بلغ العامين ورفقته اثناء عمليه
نقله عبر طائره خاصه لعلاجها في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض تفاصيل دائما معها نسبيا
تمييز بين واقع مختلف يعيشه الطفل سلمان
الان وبين حاله عندما كان في مهده اذ كاد
يفارق فيه الحياه هنا يلعبون ولا يعرف
شيئا سوى الحياه ولا يعرف ايضا كيف كانت
حالته
[موسيقى]
سنه
وتبين عنده ثقوب فتحات في القلب قبل عامين
رافقنا رحله طبيه اشبه برحله المصير
بواسطه طائره الاخلاء الطبيعه للخدمات
الطبيه بوزاره الدفاع السعوديه رحله لم
تكون شاقه بقدر ما كانت تحتاج الى السرعه
الطاقه والتطبي يتابع حاله سلمان الرضيع
الذي كان يبلغ عمره انا ذاك ثلاثه اشهر
وقلبه ضعيف قد يفقد الحياه
[موسيقى]
الرحله المصيريه والحساسه كانت مدتها 56
دقيقه جوا من محافظه خميس مشيط جنوبا الى
الرياض العاصمه
[موسيقى]
طائره طبيه جهزت لسلمان الذي كان لابد من
نقله الى مستشفى تتوفر فيه الامكانيات
الطبيه الحديثه ويمتلك طاقم طبيا مختصر
مخاطبه المستشفى الرياض
بخصوص نقل حاله الطفل الى مستشفى متقدم
لاجراء عمليه له في القلب
من ذكريات الطائره سلمان لم يكن يشعر بما
يدور حوله والده كان يحدق طيله الوقت الى
بلد كبده
بالحب كبراس سويا والان يضحكان معا
وبينهما الحب والامان
هاني صبيان العربيه الرياض
دخل فيلم الخلاط بلس قائمه توب تن عالميا
على منصه نتفليكس وذلك في الاسبوع الاول
من عرضه بعد تحقيق اكثر من مليون و500,000
ساعه مشاهده الفيلم بمشاركه عدد من النجوم
السعوديه منهم ابراهيم الخير الله وعبد
العزيز الشهري وابراهيم الحجاج
[موسيقى]
الوجه ابليسك
الطحينه
[موسيقى]
قسم العرب والسحب لعده اقسام منها نشو
انفيض والعارضه تفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد
سعد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علاقه العرب بتفاصيل السماء ومعالم الارض
علاقه حياتيه وجوديه فحياتهم متوقفه على
ما تجود بهم السماء ماء وما تخرج لهم
الارض من خيرات ولهذا نجدهم اهل تنقلوا
وترحل بحثا عن كلا الارض ومطر السماء
ونجدهم ايضا يهتمون بتفاصيل الاحوال
المناخيه من رعد وبر وسحاب واني لنجم ان
تهتدى صحبتي به اذا حاله من دون النجوم
سحابه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والعرب قسم السحب الى اقسام منها النشوء
هو السحاب المتناثر النفيض هو السحاب
المنخفض وسمي نيفيظا لانه نفض ما في جعبته
من امطار والعرض هو السحاب الممتد من جهه
الى جهه ثانيه المدن هي السحابه المنفرجه
على واجه السماء يا من لبرق ابيت الليل
ارقبه من عارض كبياض صبحي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قرر المدعي العامه التمييزي اللبنانيه
غسان عويدات اطلاقه سراحي كل الموقوفين في
قضيه انفجار مرفا بيروت قرر عويدات منع
المفرجي عنهم من السفر
وجعلهم بتصرف المجلس العدلي كما قرر عويضه
ايضا الادعاء على قاضي التحقيق في قضيه
المراه طارق البيطار وذلك بعد يوم من
ادعاء البيطار على عويدات ومنعه من السفر
الامر الذي اصبح يشبه حربا قضائيه بين
الرجلين
[تصفيق]
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه عن اغلاق تام في
العاصمه لمده خمسه ايام بسبب مرض تنفسي لم
تحدده اخطار حكوميه امر سكانا بيونج
بالبقاء في المنازل وقياس درجه الحراره
عده مرات يوميا كما لجا السكان لتخزين
المواد الغذائيه السلطات الكوريه لم تاتي
على ذكر فيروس كورونا في اخطارها لكنها
اكدت ان عدد من يعانون من ارتفاع درجه
الحراره يقترب من خمسه ملايين شخص
في اليابان غطى تثلوج الكثيفه مساحات
واسعه من البلاد واعقد حركه النقل وتسببت
الثلوج في الغاء مئات الرحلات الجويه
وتعطل حركه القطارات كما لقي شخص واحد على
الاقل حذفه وافدت وسائل الاعلام بان شركات
طيران المحليه الغت اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
رحله جويه وجرى تعليق خدمات القطارات
السريعه او تاجيلها في شمال اليابان وقالت
هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون اليابانيه ان
الجليد تسبب في توقف السيارات والشاحنات
بمسافه نحو عشره كيلو مترات على طريق
سريعا وسط اليابان واتقطعت السبل بنحو
ثلاثه الاف شخص في العديد من محطات القطار
الغربيه بعد ان ادت الثلوج والرياح القويه
الى تعليق الخدمه والتره بعض الركاب للنوم
على الارض في محطه كيوت الرئيس
ختام الرابع بابرز عناوين
الى اوكرانيا بعد توافق مع واشنطن على
ارسال دبابات ابرامز
استثماريه ضخمه للاعلانات وعن اربع مناطق
رقميه
دراسه حديثه تكشف عن تعرض 80% من الموظفين
في السعوديه لاعراض تتعلق بالصحه النفسيه
بشراكه سعوديه ايطاليه التنفيذ يبدا في
مشروع سما للاخوت والسفن الفاخره
على مدى عامين الرابعه توثيق قصه انقاذ
الطفل سلمان تجاوز ازمه قلبيه في اشهر
الاولى
[موسيقى]